I was listening to a podcast from Mel
Robbins the other day and her content is
absolutely amazing it is so easy to get
into a rabbit trail of listening from
one to another because everything she
has is is just awesome and pure gold but
this one particular podcast that I was
listening to if I can find it I'll put
it down below so that you can check it
out cuz she also has them on YouTube
version I wanted to share uh one of the
key takeaways that I got from it and I'm
nowhere near as eloquent as she is so
I'm not even going to try to summarize
or paraphrase this was a podcast where
she was talking about dreams we
unfortunately sometimes end up being the
biggest dream Crushers when it comes to
the things that we want to obtain in
life the things that we want to achieve
and and have it's sad that a lot of us
will now say we don't have dreams or we
don't have certain aspirations but in
reality she says that's a lad of BS
because we have dreams and our dreams I
mean even children have dreams whether
it might be being the first astronaut on
Mars or whatever it might be that we end
up then growing as adults and saying oh
I could never move to this particular
location because it's out of my budget
or I could never do this type of career
it's too saturated whatever the reasons
might be that we often end up listening
to that inner critic and those voices
that say that we can't achieve this
particular lifestyle that we end up
resigning ourselves not to try but we
end up unhappy in the process she goes
on to talk about how our dreams are
really not necessarily things that we're
meant to achieve and to obtain they're
really more of like a lighthouse like a
guide in order to guide us in the
correct direction in life and I
definitely resonated with this because
before I came across minimalism I was
just going through motions I was
definitely a Shopaholic and I had this
shopping addiction I felt I felt
worthless I didn't have worth Within
Myself I didn't love myself I had been a
people pleaser all my life still
something that I'm trying to work on
eliminating from myself but it it was
definitely a difficult time for me
because I felt lonely and shopping and
being on my phone and having
distractions was a lot easier than
addressing the things within me being
alone with myself meant that I had to
face myself I had to face those ugly
things that I didn't want to face it was
a lot easier to go out shopping it was a
lot easier to have a distraction of a
phone in front of my face or whatever
screen than to face the reality that I
wasn't going after the things that I
really wanted to achieve or obtain in
life so to give you the backstory of
where I was at prior to coming AC R
cross minimalism it really for me I came
across it kind of by accident I was
trying to get out of debt after having
heard about Dave ramsy and so we began
to sell some things to try to get some
money back and it wasn't a quick process
in the beginning and minimalism was
definitely not like this ponies and
rainbows and sunshine kind of experience
for me in the very beginning because I
had to ask myself questions that I had
never asked before in the first few
items it kind of was a little bit easier
it was like selling things that I never
never used that I wanted to make money
off of like selling a treadmill machine
that I didn't really use or we had like
a boxing machine thing it's like certain
things that we could make money off of
was easy cuz our goal was to get out of
debt then when it got to other things
that said more about me that's when it
got tougher and that's when I started to
face those things that I was masking and
hiding through the shopping or through
screens or whatever distractions I had
to face the fact that I wasn't living
the life that I wanted for myself the
first step in order to get decluttering
to happen faster I had to address the
stuff inside because it wasn't just
about the stuff so to give you an
example when I was going through my home
decor I had to really ask myself why did
I even purchase all this to begin with
what is what was it about this stuff
that was so important to me and that was
hard to let go why is it that any day
that my hus my husband would be at work
that I would be off why was I out
shopping and this was when I faced the
reality that I felt lonely and when it
came to my makeup box for example I had
a giant chest of makeup I still enjoy
makeup now it's in a little baggie it's
just as simple I had told myself the
story that it was because I liked it and
I had fun and I enjoyed it that wasn't
the reality the reality was I was
spending money going shopping because I
thought it was fun and putting things on
my face or whatever it might be I was
loading my home with stuff like I had
over 30 pairs of shoes over 30 pairs of
dresses I was super proud that I had
tons of different purses of big big
sizes small sizes to match with my
different shoes to match with different
necklaces all sorts of items that I
thought were fun but in reality it was
just a mask for the things that were
going on inside me and specifically this
is where I tie in the thing about the
dreams is that I had given up my desires
because I felt like certain dreams that
I had were unobtainable we have this
Compass within us and that's our dreams
and we kind of get that tugging feeling
I should be doing this or I should be
trying that but when we are too afraid
to try it or we just would want to
ignore it or say that could never work
for me that's never going to happen I
might as well just forget about it we
end up unhappy and because we can't face
that sometimes we find distractions for
it how I think that this kind of ties
back into dreaming and how we stop
dreaming and how that affects us is that
we have this potential within us we have
the potential for greatness we were
meant for greatness but we don't believe
that often and I didn't believe that I
felt like I was conforming like I was
doing the things that I should be doing
but not the things that I wanted to be
doing so what do dreams have to do with
decluttering and being able to declutter
10 times faster see the thing is your
stuff and your possessions you have them
for a particular reason and it's not
just stuff it's the stories behind them
and the stories that we tell us there's
different reasons why different people
have different things but my particular
reason was that I was trying to mask the
things that were going on inside me and
it was easier to distract myself with
purchasing than to be able to actually
face them head on and it wasn't until I
was able to actually face those things
that I was going through that I was then
able to let go of the physical stuff
because that didn't have a hold of me
anymore so where I realized that dreams
and allowing myself to dream again was
what really kickstarted my being able to
declutter a lot faster was because it
wasn't until we came across Dave Ramsey
and then the fire movement and then
minimalism that it kind of just all kind
of started to click and fall into place
I started to realize that I could have
the life that I wanted and that I should
work towards that regardless of whether
or not I actually get there that I
should work towards that direction that
my compass those dreams are telling me
to go in at that time I was working in
ICU and it's a job that I absolutely
felt thankful to be able to work in I
grew and I learned so many things but I
was definitely not my passion it's a
very very stressful difficult job
physically because I had to lift and
turn patients all the time emotionally
because when people are in such a state
uh they tend to well I'm just going to
put it bluntly a lot of people a great
majority of the patients that I had were
just not the nicest people because they
were under stress they were under
anxiety they were in a very difficult
situation in their life and I got kicked
at spat at uh cursed at numerous times
uh working in the ICU so it was
definitely stressful in that sense and
then of course uh adding to it that
people are dying and so it was just a
very difficult situation that I felt
like I was stuck I didn't know what
direction to go in I felt like I should
be happy in the job that I had and
rather than facing my issues with that
be that I was feeling stuck in a job
that I didn't absolutely love or feeling
like I wasn't working on myself and I
wasn't the person that I wanted to be
and I wasn't as confident as I wanted to
be or all these things that I didn't
like about myself it was so much easier
to go out shopping go distract myself
with screens than to face that I had to
ask myself deep questions that I had
never asked before and specifically the
questions kind of open the door for me
to allow myself to dream again Mel
Robbins says that we kind of put a cap
on our dreams and we don't allow
ourselves to obtain certain things
higher than those dreams because we are
the ones that dictate how high that seal
goes and so if you just take that lid
off and allow yourself to dream big then
you can work towards that and and
achieving that or getting to that
particular destination is not the
important thing it's what are you doing
in the process are you enjoying that
Journey when we are going against our
dreams and living a life that doesn't
align with that we tend to be grumpy we
tend to be unhappy we're not feeling as
fulfilled it wasn't until I fac those
things it wasn't until I really
acknowledged that all the home decor was
really just to distract me and feeling
trying to fill a void and and all the
makeup that I had and the shoes and the
purses and the bags they weren't filling
me they weren't things that were adding
any value to my life but rather
deterring me from being the person that
I wanted to be and that I could be the
person that I wanted to be and that I
should try to live a better lifestyle it
wasn't until I allowed myself to dream
again that I was then able to answer
those questions what do I want from my
life I guess I it kind of went backwards
actually by asking myself those
questions what is it that I want out of
my life what would I love to do with my
life then I was able to allow myself to
dream again and recognizing that I am
allowed to have dreams regardless of
whether or not other people agree with
them or would want me to go in that
direction that I need to be my biggest
cheerleader and so it kind of stemmed
from first giving myself permission to
dream again for me thankfully the fire
movement is not something that I'm
necessarily uh working towards anymore I
I definitely want to live slowly live
more intentionally but it did kind of
Kickstart that it kickstarted my
realizing that I can have the things
that I want to obtain and it made me
realize that my stuff was only getting
in the way so for me the dream that we
had at the time when we started
minimizing and decluttering was that we
wanted to get out of debt and we wanted
to own our own home my husband and I
actually end up building our own home
and I didn't mean that we hired a
builder I mean we were out here nailing
and laying out flooring and putting in
Windows and putting up siding uh that
was an incredible amount of work but
even so it was just the fact that we
allowed ourselves to dream and allowing
our El to dream then became kind of the
guide to be able to ask ourselves the
questions of if we were moving would I
want to take this and actually even now
that we live in this home that tends to
be the question that I ask myself if I
were moving a month from now 2 months
from now would I want to take this with
me and the reason that I ask myself this
question is because it goes back to the
dream thing is I want a particular
lifestyle and I can kind of picture that
in my mind now I can visualize what I
want yessie to be like 5 years from now
10 years from now I realize that I'm not
the person that I want to be but there
are certain things that I want to be
able to do certain things that I want to
change about myself so what would that
person want what would that person value
what kinds of things would that person
have in her home for example if I'm
looking at a particular item in the home
and I'm thinking if I were to move 1 to
two months from now would I take this
with me what that question does is that
it asks me about my values that is kind
of what the question is really asking
what is it that you value so much that
you'd want to pack up and and take with
you and unload and unpack there so one
of the things that I think would be
super helpful if you're struggling with
decluttering if you're feeling like it's
not going as fast as you would like for
you is to really ask yourself rather
than just asking like what your values
are because I think every channel just
kind of talks about what your values are
is what are your dreams I think that
some of us know intrinsically what our
values we value family or we value
certain projects that we have or
whatever it it might be but even though
we might value certain things our life
sometimes doesn't actually represent
that through the things that we do
because we're not living the life that
we dream for ourselves I think if you we
kind of start back with thinking about
what are our dreams and then going from
there to if I were to have that dream
now in my case it was if I was moving
what would I take with me what would I
actually want to keep and this kind of
takes it away from all the things that I
don't need and like H do I need this
item do I not need this item is which
items do I value the most which items do
I love the most which items bring me the
most joy and actually some items don't
necessarily bring you Joy but you
actually need them instead of just kind
of constantly asking yourself what do I
not need what's just bothering me I
think that that's been a huge help for
me is kind of going about it from what
are my dreams and what items are aligned
with those dreams that I have for myself
and I hope that it's an encouragement to
you to really look at your own dreams
what is it that you want to obtain in
your life what are those things that you
have kind of pushed aside that you felt
like oh there's no way I can do that or
what is it that you are wanting to
achieve or to accomplish and and go in
the direction of those dreams regardless
of the whether or not they work out or
not um my husband was talking to me a
couple of days ago because I was telling
him about this podcast and he was saying
well what if we never get to that stage
and I said that's fine if I never get to
achieve the things that I wanted to
achieve I would die happy knowing that I
lived my life in alignment with that
that I was true to that that I tried
those things rather than knowing that
I'm on my deathbed and I never even
tried and I never even knew if it would
have worked out I worked in hospice for
3 years and it completely changed my
life and whenever I face questions of
what I should or shouldn't do I I often
think of my patience because I recognize
that my time is finite that even though
they were oftentimes much older than I
that I could be young and I could pass
tomorrow I don't know that my time is
not guaranteed and actually it's not our
time we don't have time in the same way
that we have money in our pocket it's
really something that often times I take
for granted and I want to make sure that
I live my life in alignment with the
things that I value and to try to pursue
the dreams that I have and so I want to
encourage you to do the same ask
yourself what are your dreams what are
those things that you would love to
achieve and don't necessarily pursue it
for the very benefit of having obtain
those things but just for the thrill of
knowing you did it of knowing that you
tried and you live in alignment with
that wouldn't that be an incredible life
and that would I think take away from
having to constantly think should I have
this item should I not have this item I
think minimalism is incredible it's been
an incredible tool for me that has
changed my life dramatically but I think
that it's so easy to go down this Rabbit
Hole to go down this trail of going to
extremes of thinking of every single
little item do I need two paper clips do
I need one paper clip it's really not
about that it's really not about having
a specific number of items and so I
think uh if you could consider going
just a step Step Beyond that and
considering yes not only your values but
consider your dreams again and allow
yourself to dream and allow yourself
give yourself permission to dream again
then your decluttering would go a lot
faster and hopefully you'd be living a
life that aligns with those dreams
that's it for this video it felt like a
rant but I hope that this video has been
encouraging to you and just letting you
know that it's okay to dream be your
biggest cheerleader and go after those
dreams thank you so much for watching if
you like this video please don't forget
to give it a Thumbs Up And subscribe so
you won't miss when I post a new video I
thank you so much for watching until
next time bye